[يضحك]
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قبعة.
لا يذهب و
[موسيقى]
الكل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
zhenya هناك بالنسبة لي لسماع مثل هذا
الرقص بالقرب من بعضها البعض
معاقبة هؤلاء 4 5 6 بدون المقبلات مع الباليه
وهنا إلى النور الذي سيشعلني
قدم لنفسه عرضًا يمكنك حتى
للمشاركة في نادينا أنت لست عضوًا فيه
المرحلة ستكون خارج الترتيب للهدايا بشكل جيد
ما الذي يميز الآن لا يوجد أحد
ساعة و 20 دقيقة في البرد وبأمان معها
تعاملنا مع هذا ليس القتال
مثل الأدغال ، حافظ على التوازن والآن هكذا
ليس بأمر قتالي وليس أصعب
ثم حاول التأكد من أن الجميع
اتضح بنعم اليدين
[موسيقى]
لا تقسم كثيرا وصورة الناقد
رأى محتوى مكافحة التجسس و
كانت الوصفات على هذا النحو مع كل خطوة تقوم بها
تحميل على أيدي أعماق الخاص بك هذا هو
أصدقاء القرية لدينا 1 من 6 أزواج
الذي حدث ووقعت
رأيت هذا الحب هنا أو
تغير في المظهر قال الجمهور أن الزوجين
حتى وفصلنا ننظر
اعتراض السراويل الضيقة السفلية بقوة
هوتي المساء قد اضغط على الثانية و
المركز الأول أو بنك موسكو ميركور
تصفيق وستتاح لك الفرصة
انتقد هذا أكثر من علامتنا التجارية
neve هدية أخرى للزوجين pa ti li
في المقام الأول من الآخرين والتصفيق
كل خير صيدلية
لكن
طار